These are some baby names I loved, but I didn't use this time around.
For reference,
our kids have pretty unique names.
Our daughter's name is Rumble Honey Smith,
our son's name is Slim Easy Smith,
and then we just had little whimsy Lou Smith.
So these might be a little out there.
A little bit more controversial,
but in case someone needs any ideas for their kids.
These are some girls names that I loved.
We were almost gonna name her tank.
And then I love the name Bo, as in bow as a second name.
I also really liked fruit names, so I love the name Lemon,
Plum and Clementine.
Also really liked Pippin or Pip for short,
Dottie or dot for short,
and then Ivy as well, just because that would have almost been my name.
And then for boys.
Boys are a little bit trickier to name in my opinion.
But we had the name Halo on our list,
thus also do Mercer and flick.
So yeah, those were some names that we didn't end up using,
but that were still on my list.